this week the palms will be playing host
to a world championship event for
gymnastics yeah as kirsten joyce reports
the majority of athletes representing
team usa in the competition are from las
vegas
seven eight it's an exciting time inside
the fitness center at mcdonald highlands
where these aerobic gymnasts are gearing
up for a serious competition the elite
youth international invitational
championship we're going to have new
zealand canada canada japan and team usa
compete with each other taller kinsey
taller founder of elite youth stephanie
firstall brought the sport from hungary
to henderson it combines traditional
aerobics with dynamic strength and
flexibility all performed to music i
love what i do and this is my passion
and purpose in life to elevate every
single kid to their highest potential so
this is my honor and it's a true
blessing for me chin up dressed up smile
as a global sport elite youth the only
team representing team usa comprised of
athletes from mostly las vegas as well
as arizona and texas it takes a lot of
hard work and determination and
commitment
for six years 14 year old melody willem
has been mastering the sport i love it
eleven-year-old emily sloan loves the
leadership aspect what do you see in the
future elite gets into the olympics and
i'm in the olympics we're using an nlp
technique which is a neuro-linguistic
programming through their conscious and
unconscious mind and while we are
talking to them we're not just elevating
their physical body but they we are
elevating their mental health as well
and we are creating leaders instead of
followers leaders who are going for the
gold this week
[Applause]
three one two three
kirstjen joyce live local now
well that's awesome right there elite
youth is always looking for additional
sponsors to help elevate these athletes
to the next level you can find their
information over on our website